بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
الدرس موصول
حول فاصل الاخلاق
اخلاق النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من كتاب
تهذيب الاسماء واللغات للحافظ النووي رحمه
الله
وهذا الدرس في زاد المعاد
زاد المعاد من تاليف شمس الدين ابن القيم
لكن اخذ كثيرا من
بدايات تبويب زاد المعاد من تهذيب الاسماء
واللغات للنووي رحمه الله
من ذكر
صفات النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الخلقيه
والخلقيه وكذلك
في اسامي مؤذنيه وكتابه
ومواليه وازواجه وابنائه واعمامه وهلم جره
فنقرا من
فصل الاخلاق في اصل الكتابين الذي هو في
تهذيب الاسماء واللغات للنوي رحمه الله
لانه اتم شيئا ما
ونريد ان نستقصي جميع ما ذكر في خلقه صلى
الله عليه وسلم وبعد ذلك فيه خلقه يعني في
صفاته الخلقيه كيف كان وجهه ولحيته
وبعد ذلك في
في
اياته صلى الله عليه وسلم التي تسمى عند
المتاخرين المعجزات نذكر اكثر هذه
المعجزات ان شاء الله تعالى وهي كثيره جدا
تربو على الالف لكن نذكر رؤوس هذه
المعجزات
انوي
زاد
المعادن 5
زائد المعادن
[Silence]
الحافظ ابن القيم رحمه الله
الفزاد البعاد من ذهنه وهو في طريقي الى
الحج
مرتب ترتيب عاده الكتب لا ضيف لا باس في
ذلك
ونفذ الثاني
ابن القيم رحمه الله وانت حاج
في تسعه
[Silence]
يعني الظاهر من صنيع ابن القيم رحمه الله
انه اراد ان يكتب ما املى عليه خاطره
وعفو الخاطر
ولم يكن يقصد في هذا الكتاب زاد المعاد ان
يكون ما كان لانه مع مر الايام زادت
الفكره عنده فلما زادت
واراد ان
وكانت هذه الفكره ناضجه في ذهنه اراد ان
يستقصي ما فاته في بدايه الكتاب مما هو
مقصود له الكتاب ضخم جدا
هو سوده
رحمه الله تعالى ثم قد تكون اخترمته
المنيه قبل ان يبيض الكتاب
ويعيد النظر فيه وهذا امر لازم
فلذلك ناخذ من اصل هذا الكتاب في
سرد اخلاق النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من
كتاب تهذيب الاسماء اللغات للنووي الذي هو
اصل للكتابين
وبعد ذلك نذكر كما
اسلفنا
صفات خلقه صلى الله عليه وسلم الصفات
الخلقيه بعد الخلقيه وبعد ذلك ان شاء الله
اياته سويه
يوسف زاد المعاد
تهذيب الاسماء واللغات
والحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى
ابن القيم روت زاد المعاد في رمامه
[Silence]
ابن القيم رحمه الله
وتجانز
لان تهذيب الاسماء واللغات
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
والله سبحانه
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
وكان اكثر الناس تواضعا
يقضي حاجه اهله
ويخفض جناحه للضعفه
وما سئل شيئا قط فقال له
وطبعا هذا عند الجده اما اذا كان صلى الله
عليه وسلم لا يجد ما يعطي
فانه
يرد بالمعروف وبالاحسان يقول الله تعالى
قول معروف ومغفره خير من صدقه يتبعها اذى
هو صلى الله عليه وسلم من جاءه
وهو في حاجه
ويستطيع النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ان يقضي
له حاجته فانه لا يتوانى في ذلك
لكن اذا كانت ليست لديه الجده ما عنده ما
يسد حاجه السائل الا انه لا يرد احدا
صفرا
صفرا لا يرد احدا بالتمام انما يرد
بالمعروف ويعلمه من الحكمه
بعض الصحابه سالوه سالوه حتى لم يجد فقال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لهم
من تصبر يصبره الله
ومن استعفف يعفه الله او يعفه الله
وما اعطي احد عطاء اوسع وخيرا من الصبر
وعلمهم من الحكمه فصحيح جاؤوا لحاجه ماديه
ولم يستطع ان
يسد حاجتهم الا انه لم يردهم صفرا فرجعوا
بفائده
ونجد هذا كمان ليس فقط في الذي ياتي
ويساله شيئا من الدنيا
يعني
جاءه رجل
كما في الصحيحين من حديث ابي هريره حديث
بجوز يعرفه كثير منا لكن
الانسان يتفكر بهذه الروايه وهذا مثال
جاءه رجل
وقال
الكتو جاءه يقول هلكته
فساله ما بك
اخبره انه
غلباته نفسه
فجامع زوجته في نهار رمضان
مشكله هذه كبيره من كبائر الذنوب اليس
كذلك افطر فاضطر غيره وتواضع على العصيان
لكن لما ننظر الى نهايه الحديث
جاء الرجل اليه وهو يقول هلكت
وعاد الى اهله
بطعام كيف جاء يقول هلكته فساله ماذا بك
فقال وقعت على امراتي وانا صائم في نهار
رمضان
فقال له
هل تجد
رقبه
فتعتقها قال لا
قال فهل
استطيع ان تطعم ستين مسكينا
لا
هل تستطيع ان تطعم ستين مسكينا قال ما في
حدا في المدينه افقر مني
فسكت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فجيئه
بسل فيها تمر
واعطاه الرجل وقال اطعم اهلك يعني الرجل
جاء وهو يقول هلاكت
وعاد الى اهله بماذا
وهكذا كان الذي يذهب الى النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وهذا نموذج
النووي رحمه الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم ماوس
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم ليفدنتايم
وان مان حارس
[Silence]
سمان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
سدهم او املك ان كان الله نازع الرحمه من
قلوبكم
لكن
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
مين
[Silence]
سيتي
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الولي الاولياء
الى اخره الله سبحانه وتعالى يوزج
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ياس صلى الله عليه وسلم سوايس الله
[Silence]
النووي رحمه الله
ويخفض جناحه للضعفه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
يقول وكان احلم الناس
وكان احلم الناس
المقصود باحلى من الناس من اسماء الله
سبحانه وتعالى الحليم
وهذا الحلم الذي كان
صفه للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهي صفه الله
وقد جاء في الروايه بان اهل هذه الامه
الله عز وجل
يعطيهم من علمه وحلمه سبحانه وتعالى لامه
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم خير الامم ولا
حلم ولا علم
قالوا كيف ولا حلم ولا علم قال اعطيهم من
حلمي وعلمي
المقصود هنا بالحلم
العفو وعدم الانتقام
ليس يعني انه لا يغضب الانسان بعض الناس
يظن ان الحلم بمعنى انه لا تاخذه غضب ابدا
غلط
الانسان لو احنا وجدنا انسان
بارد على الاخر
بارد الاعصاب ما في اشي بزعله حتى الاشياء
اللي المفروض تزعلوه
ماشي
وحدا
حدا يعتدي على اهله حدا والرجل لا يغضب
يقول الرسول ما كان يغضب الناس
انتهك حوله محارم الله ومحارمه وهو لا
يغضب نقول هذا ماذا
هذا ضعف هذا ليس قوه
بل الانسان يغضب
اذا انتهكت حرمات الله
والحلم هو ان الانسان لا ينتقم
ويحلم
عن المسيء يحلم عن المسيء
من ذلك ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم كما
في صحيح البخاري
جاء
ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
ليس
احد وفي لفظ ليس شخص
اصبر من الله على اذى سمعه
ينسبون له الولد
وهو
يعافيهم
ويرزقهم هذا من ايش من حلم الله سبحانه
وتعالى
والا السماوات تكاد تتفطر من
وتخر الجبال
وتنشق الارض
من هذا القول من دعوه الولد لله سبحانه
وتعالى ولكن الله عز وجل لا ياذن بذلك
لماذا لانه حليم يحلم سبحانه وتعالى عن
المسيء عن الانسان
يصبر على الانسان الضعيف الجاهل
وهذا مثل قول الله سبحانه وتعالى خذ العفو
وامر بالعرف واعرض عن الجاهلين هذا
الاعراض عن الجاهل
فهذا هو الحلم
حلم عدم الانتقام
من
الجاهل والمعتدي
فهو صلى الله عليه وسلم كان احلم الناس
وثم روايات كثيره
ما لاتماعنا من صغرنا ان النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم كان يؤذى هكذا ويؤذى بهذا
ويؤذونه بكيت وكيت وهو يحلم عنهم ويصفح
ويغفر عليه الصلاه والسلام والله عز وجل
امره
بالعفو عن اعدائه من
المشركين واهل الكتاب في مكه قبل
تشريع القتال قال تعالى
فاعفوا واصفحوا حتى ياتي الله بامره ان
الله على كل شيء قدير
وكان ماذا من امره شرع الجهاد بعد ذلك
والجزيه فعلى كل حال
هذا هو الحلم فاذا قلنا النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم كان احلم الناس يعني كان لا
ينتقم عليه الصلاه والسلام لنفسه ابدا
وانما ينتقم لله واذا في مجال العفو
والصافح فهو ايضا
يشفع
للناس في ذلك
النووي رحمه الله
[Silence]
عليه وسلم يعني
عبد الله بن ابي
برافت صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
والذي تولى كبره منه هذا الذي تولى كبره
يعني اكبر المشكله كانت منه هذا عبد الله
بن ابي بن سلول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
انتقم منه
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول وكان اشد حياء من العذراء في خدرها
كان اشد حياء من العذراء في خدرها
يعني صلى الله عليه وسلم لم يكن فاحش
الكلام
وليس في مجلسه
ما يكون في بعض المجالس من وصف
وصف النساء من ذكر الفواحش وحتى الفاحش من
الكلام والفاحش في لغه العرب
والزائد عن حده هذا يقال فاحش ماشي وكان
يكني صلى الله عليه وسلم
في الكلام لا يذكر الالفاظ البذيئه ولا
تذكر في مجلسه صلى الله عليه وسلم
وايضا
حث على
ان يكون المؤمن
غير فاحش الكلام فقال ليس المؤمن بالفاحش
ولا البذيء
ليس بالفاحش ولا البذيء
حتى انه كان يتحرج احيانا ان يصف بعض
احكام شرعيه
لبعض النساء في مسائل
فازواجه او بناته
يعني بعض ازواجه او بناته تاخذ الاخت او
تاخذ المراه وتعلمها من الامور التي تحتاج
الى شيء من الدقه وذكر بعض الاشياء فكان
يتحرج من ذلك لانه كان
حيا عليه الصلاه والسلام
[Silence]
ورد فاحش الفحش
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
يقول
والقريب والبعيد والقوي والضعيف عنده في
الحق سواء
ما هو الامر الجامع الامر الجامع الحق
ان كان على الحق
فيستوي عنده القوي والضعيف
والقريب والبعيد والمسلم والكافر المساله
لمساله حق العدل
والباطل الباطل
سواء جاء هذا من القريب او من البعيد او
القوي او الضعيف او المسلم او الكافر
الباطل الباطل ويبطل
ويترك وينكر فهكذا كان صلى الله عليه وسلم
وذلك في حكمه وفي غير حكمه
هؤلاء كلهم في الحق عنده سواء
من كان له حق وكان ضعيفا فانه ياخذ حقه
وكانه سيد القوم
ومن كان
لغيره عنده حق فانه
يساق وانه يقتص
من المحقوق
ولو كان سيد القوم لو كان من يكون فان
الحق لابد ان يحقق
والباطل يبطل
وهو يقول في هذا الوصف الجميل وهذا من
قصه ومن وصف جاء عن علي بن ابي طالب رضي
الله عنه عند الترمذي واكثر هذه الجمل هي
ماخوذه من كتب الحديث ماخوذه كما جاء
الوصف تماما باللفظ والمعنى عن الصحابه
رضي الله عنهم فهذه قطعه من حديث جاء من
طريق الحسين بن علي عن ابيه علي بن ابي
طالب
وحفيد عن ابيه عن النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم انه قال القريب والبعيد والقوي
والضعيف عنده في الحق سواء
ونعرب
تهم
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى
وما عاب طعاما قط
ان اشتهاه اكله
والا تركه
وهذا ليس يعني
ان الانسان مثلا اذا كان متزوجا
ومرته بدها تفهم عليه عشان تعرف مثلا كيف
تطبخ له يا فلان بتحب هاي وما بتحب هاي
انه يقول مثلا هذا الملح كثيرة وهذا شيء
عادي هذا ليس من الاعابه هنا المذكوره في
هذه الجمل وانما المقصود انه اذا قدم اليه
طعام
فانه لا يعيب الطعام لان الطعام نعمه من
الله سبحانه وتعالى وهذا من شان الملوك
ليس من شان العبيد
جاء عند الطبراني في المعجم ان النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم قال
اكل كما ياكل العبد
واجلس كما يجلس العبد فانما نعبد هكذا قال
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وكان لا يعيب الطعام ان اشتهاه اكل
وان لم يشتهي
هذا الاكل فانه لا ياكل عليه الصلاه
والسلام
ناظره
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال ولا ياكل متكئا ولا على خوان
وياكل ماتيسر
ولا ياكل
متكئا
الاتكاء في لغه العرب
المقصود به
ان يضع الانسان
يمينه او يساره اما
بالكف على الارض او بالكوع على الارض
وان يميل على جنبه فهذا هو الاتكاء
الاتكاء يكون على الكف ويكون على
هنا عجوع برضو الانسان يتكئ على ايده هيك
هذا اتكاء في لغه العرب او يتاكل على اللي
احنا بنقوله على الجوع هذا اتيكا
فهو كان صلى الله عليه وسلم لا ياكل متكئا
لماذا هذا هذه جلسه الملوك في الاكل وهذه
جلسه اهل الجنه في الجنه على الارائك
متكئين صح ولا لا هذا في الجنه هؤلاء
يكونون ملوك الجنه لكن في الارض فهذا لا
ينبغي ينبغي للانسان ان يتقعر في
التذلل لله سبحانه وتعالى في جميع احواله
هكذا كان صلى الله عليه وسلم فهو قال
الحديث الذي
اسنادوه حسن ويتقوى
قال
اجلسوا كما يجلس العبد واكل كما ياكل
العبد فانما انا عبد والمقصود
اكل كما ياكل العبد
يعني انه لا يزيد في الاكل
لا يزيد
العبيد عاده في زمن الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم ما ياكلون الاطعمه الفاخره
وياكلون يعني الى الشبع وزياده لا
وانما ياكل القليل ويكتفي بالقليل تواضعا
لله سبحانه وتعالى
والعكس هو الصحيح عند الكافرين النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم
يقول المؤمن ياكل
بمعن واحدا
والكافر
في سبعه امعاء
يعني من شان الكافر انه
يخبط منها الاكل لما انه
لكن المؤمن لا يفعل هذا
ونجد هذا حتى فيه صنيع غير المسلمين مثلا
في واحد
سيعدم مثلا لو في اعدام
المؤمن يعني واحد من نقول سمح الله بده
ينعدم
يحب انه يلاقي ربه ايش مليان البطن بجوز
اكثرنا صح ولا لا لكن عند غير المسلمين
بقول لك لا الاكل الاخيره هذه الاكله
الاخيره
كل يا عمي لو انك تنصح بعبي هالطاوله من
الطلبات يعني حتى المساجين وكذا هذا مشهور
عنهم لكن المسلم ياكل كما ياكل العبد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الاتكاء
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى
يفترش يسراه ويرفع
ركبته اليمنى الى صدره وياكل صلى الله
عليه وسلم وهذه فيها فائده اخرى انه
الانسان ما يزيد في الاكل
لانه الانسان اذا افترش اليسرى او افترش
اليمنى ورفع الثاني على بطنها
ويكون حول الطعام
رجله فاخذه ذايكه على بطنه
فهو لا يستطيع ان ياكل ياكل ياكل براحه لا
ياكل ويشعر بالامتلاء قبل ان يمتلي تمتلي
المعده يجلد برافت صلى الله عليه وسلم
عندي
[Silence]
نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد